our top story tonight is back in
Washington with the president's longtime
lawyer and former chief problem solver
exacerbated some long-running problems
for his former boss in high-profile
testimony on Capitol Hill Michael Cohen
told a House committee and millions on
television that the president is a
racist a con man and a cheat
Republicans say Cohen who's about to go
to prison for lying to Congress is a
fraud stirrer a cheat and a convicted
felon who should not be trusted chief
intelligence correspondent Catherine
Herridge has been following all the
developments she has the substance
behind today's name-calling on Capitol
Hill tonight
well thank you Brendon good evening the
seven-hour testimony indicates that
president Trump's greatest legal
jeopardy may be in the Southern District
of New York and not Russian collusion
Cohen testified that he was instructed
not to answer questions about
conversations that took place after an
April 20 18 F bi raid
unfortunately this topic is actually
something that's being investigated
right now by the Southern District of
New York and I've been asked by them not
to discuss it not to talk about these
issues Michael Cohen the president's
long-serving and now disgraced attorney
went before a top congressional
committee mr. Trump's former fixer
telling lawmakers he needs to fix one
more thing I am here under oath to
correct the record to answer the
committee's questions truthfully and to
offer the American people what I know
about President Trump Cohen not mincing
his words I am ashamed because I know
what mr. Trump is he is a racist he is a
con man and he is a cheat
from the outset Republicans urged their
colleagues not to forget Cohen's track
record with the truth the first
announced witness for the 116th Congress
is a guy who was going to prison in two
months for lying to Congress
Cohen testified that he decided to lie
about a trumped our real estate project
he was not directed by the president to
mislead Congress he lied about it
because he never expected to win
he also lied about it because he stood
to make hundreds of millions of dollars
Cohen said the President signed checks
along with his son Don jr. in 2017 to
cover payments to silence stormy Daniels
who claimed an affair with the president
the payments were designed to be paid
over the course of 12 months was their
retainer agreement there is no retainer
agreement on Russian collusion Cohen
alleged the call between candidate Trump
and political operative Roger stone over
the hack Democratic emails mr songz told
mr. stone
that within a couple of days there would
be a massive dump of emails that would
damage Hillary Clinton's campaign and
Cohen claimed the president was guilty
of other indiscretions you're a
pathological aaja chol liar you don't
know truth from from trap from falsehood
sir are you my time and I am going to
prison I will be away from my wife and
family Republicans are not convinced
about Cohen's moral awakening alleging
he may have a lot to gain from his
testimony testimony here could actually
help you out and getting your sentence
lessened isn't that true I'm not really
sure how my appearance here today is
providing substantial information that
the southern district can use today
Republican congressman Mark meadows took
the initial steps to make a criminal
referral alleging Cohen had violated the
foreign agents Registration Act or Farra
over his work for Kazakhstan among other
nations Meadows also pointed to
discrepancies in Cohen's testimony today
Cole will be back on the hill tomorrow
for a third day this time in front of
the House Intelligence Committee for a
closed-door session Brett
catherine herridge live on the hill
after a long day Catherine thank you